Okay.
This morning I was browsing the David Pakman
show, sub Reddit.
Over 17,000 of our viewers and listeners are
now subscribed to the David Pakman show subreddit.
Find it free at David pakman.com/reddit one
of the largest progressive independent media
subreddits out there.
A couple of interesting conversations and
posts that I found.
One from Portland, hipster 69 who says Fox
is still doing infomercials during impeachment.
They are literally selling pillows from Australia
during impeachment.
Yeah, so last week when it was the house impeachment
managers presenting their case, Fox news ran
video of the impeachment proceedings, but
very often the sound would be muted and you
would either have bomb throwing ideologues
saying things over the impeachment hearings
or sometimes they would go to commercials
like my pillow.
I later found out that the MyPillow guy, the
owner of the my pillow company, I guess is
a huge Trump supporter.
I had no idea.
Sorry.
As I hit my microphone.
Um, and uh, reports are that Fox is continuing
to do this to some degree, although they seem
to air a lot more of the Trump lawyers presentations
with audio than they did the house managers.
Not a huge surprise.
A nostalgic cyan says, uh, has anyone noticed
the large amount of Mike Bloomberg ads?
I swear to God, 75% of my YouTube videos have
a Bloomberg ad.
This is seriously so annoying.
If I had a dollar for every time I heard Mike,
we'll get it done.
I could lobby Congress for legalizing weed.
Yes.
And what we are seeing is that the Bloomberg
ads are running wall to wall on YouTube, particularly
if you live in a, um, a super Tuesday state.
Super Tuesday States are the States that vote
on March 3rd, Massachusetts is a super Tuesday
state.
I'm getting Mike Bloomberg ads, not even on
political content.
I'll watch like you know, a, a Japanese omakase
save video from someone visiting Tokyo and
it'll still run an ad, uh, for Michael Bloomberg
or I will watch Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura's
online, uh, YouTube videos and I will still
get an ad for Michael Bloomberg.
So he is pouring cash into super Tuesday States
and other States expect it to continue.
And in fact, this is the strategy I said on
Monday, if I were Michael Bloomberg, this
is exactly what I would be doing.
Uh, so yes, I, a lot of people are telling
me all I get on YouTube now are Michael Bloomberg
ads.
We're just
going to have
to live with it for awhile.
Anyway, join the discussion on the
subreddit@davidpakman.com slash Reddit